[Music]
so
[Music]
just having a quick snack and then we'll
be ready
[Music]
so
[Music]
what's up gamers
what am i doing where's my phone
all right no led lights today i know
it's gonna be tough
let me pull up the game whoa
is it supposed to look like that isn't
it cropped in
yeah let me see if i can improve the
quality
of the actual stream uh it's gonna go
black just give it one sec
how's that is that better
is it noticeable
oh yeah we were doing this
um i feel like i have to keep saying
this i like the game i'm having fun
playing it otherwise i wouldn't be
playing it trust me
is my headphones acting up
i can only hear in my left ear
what the [ __ ] is that for me or you as
well
oh i forgot about this [ __ ] let him go
guys guys oh no
it's hanging by a thread
how did this happen edgar did you do
something
[Music]
you can't hear any audio from the game
well that's because i muted it
i'm the worst streamer okay i'll hear in
my left ear this one
it's shop time
yo you can't hit me
can't hit me
should i kill him they forgot it was me
this sword is so good
yeah i got this already
i heard somewhere that uh
samurais or in world war ii would
be drugged up on opium
so they would just they would shoot them
but they would just keep attacking
so they had to invent stronger guns just
to take them down
because the regular guns weren't
powerful enough because they were all
just drugged up
dude what a [ __ ] massacre what's
happening here
all right we'll sneak out with my boy i
don't know if that's true
this is something i heard and i was like
that sounds crazy
that's me right now you didn't see
anything
if you see nothing your panties are
hanging out cringe
carry the body through the car i can do
that
he glitching out he's fine
[ __ ] put him down
see how bad the gun it there we go
that's very good
yeah yeah yeah where's my boy
are you okay bro let me just take
who's shooting me
bro oh my god who's shooting oh they're
up here
chop knees [ __ ]
am i gonna die i might i might i might
take it easy
might actually have to shoot him here
this gun is way better isn't it
very dead how you guys doing
they're all missing their heads this is
so sad
oh you're not there we go no
hi hey hey
stinky all right
there's one more
i can't open the door anyway
[Music]
wait i completed the job
[Music]
what the [ __ ] bro he's right there
oh i'll take this guy out
there he goes oh there's more
not even close bro
oh please drop a katana oh
is it good no i don't think so
it says i did the quest
i can't even pick him up anymore
look at him no i can
he's fine he's fine
trust me he's fine
this is uh having a rough day
we all get it sometimes i can't loot
while holding and [ __ ] it
i shoot me through it where's the car
again
cool enemies appearing out of nowhere
almost insta killing me nice
[ __ ] oh
i gotta be careful here you know
damn son see that [ __ ] are they on the
roof
no he's inside
oh here you are
i want to see if i can go in is there
anything in here
can i use this please please cyberpunk
no fun no fun allowed
why was that door locked you can just
enter from there
there's got to be something good in here
and i was right
100 correct
yeah it feels very borderline see
sometimes this game
all right oh he's fine now before he was
stuck he's back to life it's a miracle
[Music]
this game is perfect by the way
i need to restart the mission but it
says collect the 15 grand
i can just do that right
no
no oh don't make me kill you
you may need well that means i may not
uh
what was it it was called big japan
wasn't it
yeah pick up the body okay
done see we're good we're good we're
good we're good
where the [ __ ] did he go get rid of it
i'm happy oh he's in there
get closed
[Music]
we're good we're good
sorry sorry
i got a guy in the trunk i'm innocent
please
i got boots i bet you
i can't wear them every time i get a
hope
in this game to get legs and boots
it's all gone
[Music]
there we go money please job's done i
see that well done excellent work oh
look he's fine now
my payment this is all very heartwarming
but you haven't paid me yet
i know here may this blade serve you oh
yes i got a blade
where where
it doesn't do as much damage [ __ ]
[ __ ] god damn it what are we cooking
here boy
what's your own self you got meatballs
can i have some meatballs
you cooking some meatballs bro
see we have this one now wait which one
are we using we're using this
i'm so confused
see these are not as good
fine oh you can mod it later
all right can we wear the boots
oh my god we can wear boots guys
i feel like even though we're doing the
meme they do give a lot of armor i feel
like i should
probably not right
okay
this is way better okay
should i ask for a name what's your name
again
all right is this my car now no
we got boots boys we got [ __ ] boots
this is it let's call the car
every time i click the wrong goddamn bun
thank you
i think the game saves after each quest
i don't have to quick say oh
nice all right let's collect
15 grand
whoa
the [ __ ] are you get back here get back
here no no no no
no no no no no i'm gonna [ __ ] even
[ __ ] you up [ __ ]
the [ __ ] are you doing
huh get out get out
get out
oh my god get out why can't i interact
don't honk at me all right oh it's dumb
you [ __ ] you [ __ ] i can't shoot them
you [ __ ] can i [ __ ] up their car
i'm so pissed
this game this [ __ ] game
all right collect want to go i want to
try to help my helmet and start at the
afterlife sure but the place
change okay we got to go to the
afterline why is it not showing up on
the map
is that the afterlife no
where's afterlife
the ncpd
should we do a main quest then well that
was a main quest
uh hi danger are we
in aren't we in japan downtown that
might be close
yeah that's somewhat close let's do that
[Music]
[ __ ] now this game is so broken it's
unbelievable
so
it's so good though like it looks
amazing
i love the vibes
but i would not recommend this game i'd
say wait
give it give it six months
when they fixed it
or maybe a little longer why is he
telling me to drive here
yeah we're back on the main quest now
hell yeah
like look at that it's so [ __ ] cool
[ __ ] i miss my exit because of poo
i thought i hit that
where is it telling me to go
oh in the tunnel
this is kind of dope
why is he stopping
[Music]
i can't drive
what
there we go what wait what it keeps
stopping am i out of gas
[Music]
i mean i can walk but
all right
[Music]
let's just accept the game is broken and
stop trying to get around it
now we wait
it is good to see you seems pretty uh
secluded here it is appropriate for such
a secret meeting
all right what's this friend you're
talking about ola
he should be here any moment now willing
finally to give me the spec on
him
hanako arasakas from the carrier oh
billy alice has been here
sabro's daughter yes and if he believes
you
will next meet with her
can we trust him sure you can trust him
yes
convincing very i have nothing to lose
is that better worse cause i got plenty
to lose
a good sign he is usually camouflaged
broken is my podcast [ __ ] you're right
nice did you guys see that
i'm sit i'm sitting on this thing that's
why i look tall
i was confused too
perfect
is this him your thief
he's my witness can't speak for myself
you know
so speak i have been told you know
things
yeah let's tell them spill the beans
you're a nobu strangle the old guy
silence
but it is
my one concern is to keep her safe
in this city forgotten by the gods is
she in danger
now no yet during the parade to honor
arasaka
i bring you this witness to his murder
and do you dare to worry about the silly
parade
fool correct i'm
but you can't ignore the truth sorry
that was a bitter bro
correct unlike you i have not yet failed
to keep my oath
to do my duty you will regret those
words
the only thing i regret is that i came
here to meet you
well this one well on your head i do you
a flavor now
by not cutting it off and taking it
straight to your noble summer
this is going to take much longer
uh sorry it's a cool design
i do no favors i will deliver you a head
to yorinogosama
oh what we're talking about a guy who
killed his father to seize control of
our osaka
gonna take an interest in this or not i
will not
but i will let you leave this place this
city
unharmed if i see either of you again
i will not be so lenient be very careful
my friend i don't think he's a friend or
so far from home
can't say we didn't try we tried
yes and obtained something useful
how do you figure that
what order said they returned whoa
after the parade do you not see
the parade it is our chance
perhaps if somehow
we can get to hanako we must do a proper
reconnaissance
first we'll need a precise map of japan
town
hold on it is your turn to call on
friends do you know a fixer who could
help
no just to fix her dame kaku akata
runs a pachinko parlor on jig jig street
we must pay this woman a visit
will you join me yeah sure why not
all right let's do it
don't hit me with the car please
yeah look yeah atmosphere is so cool
am i going with him all right
gg street what is this name
just a night city name
beware you mock me too often
you mock me i was just about to say his
car is kind of [ __ ]
but maybe i'll keep that to myself how
are you
i kind of like when they asked that you
all right guro
yes why the sudden concern
have shared interests you and i where
have you forgotten
certainly not good because catching lead
in night city is easier than catching a
cold
and i need you alive i am alive and
well as you can see you shouldn't worry
about yourself
any idea what's going on at arasaka
only what i can summarize from what i
see on tv
your innova and his puppets going at the
cameras and
insist that everything is under control
but the wider the smile the bigger the
light
i like that he drives so
[ __ ] slow you're right compared to
the
bike rides this is painful dude
holy [ __ ]
oh my god step on it
there's something kind of fun about just
looking out in the window in the world
excuse me
never mind i'll be looking at my knees
can i skip this ride should i do that
cool here we are
mmm
oh my god he's still so slow
if it's been with you for almost 10
years now i'm in military intelligence
analyst that's dope
[Music]
okay whoa
we're going to wakanda
oh okay
i get it you get jiggy at the jig street
aren't you cold i could warm you up
no thanks no thanks i'm married
i'm a married oh i'm a married man how
do i get out take me out
just checking out
ooh pee pee pee pee store
hell yeah pee pee store ah keanu you're
checking out the pee pee store
sweet
[ __ ] yeah pp store
pewdiepie reference
epic now i may not be good with names
but i do have quite a talent for faces
where have i seen yours before on the tv
very unlikely you didn't see nothing but
of course
the man the legend in the flash
oh you're just in time do you know who
this is
the late night comedy host
can you still do your famous better
bugger up
[Laughter]
[Music]
with your sense of humor why not
this game is very popular
bro where's your neck bro
remind me i gotta do mine no never
my boys know their place i i'm sorry i
got to go
i have guests
well well who do i spy but v
in my humble parlor no less mucaco
long time no see so what
no negan and your charming friend is
happen to be working together that's all
this is
true gentleman oh
shame only that he's being hunted by all
our osaka's tin soldiers
and uv bring him to my door
give me one reason why i shouldn't
notify the proper authorities right away
we want business why always about
eddie's wakako
you want to make them we got biz it
doesn't get any simpler
so tell me and mark well i still have my
phone at hand need intel on the parade
that's scheduled to come through japan
parade sounds fun
what i fail to understand is why come to
me
did mr deshawn not come to the phone i
feel alive
come on got your finger on the hood's
pulse know everything
parade honoring saburo arasaka
you're prepping in some way no doubt
won't
see me dressed in mourning
but the rest is true i read it before it
translated
i am sony everything's on the shards
how much does this cost my pockets
are empty clearly
my gift to you it's free oh
what is free often proves most costly
oh
japan town whole district is to be
sealed off for the parade
dashi platforms the main attraction is
the parade cool fly this way
high above street level along the parade
route
balconies footbridges and vantage points
affording good views
i feel like it will be very cool a guest
of honor
will deliver her speech from the largest
float
she'll do this exactly here
got no idea about security but given
recent
events expect it to be tight
our last parade sucker undercovers
infiltrated the crowd
did you have all this already planned
out
and if that's not enough fun for one day
a net
runner one at least they use the city
cctv to observe
everything main access point here
it's an old automated control center
if you ask me most useful by far
at the end the floats are float out
and we'll be left with trash up to our
elbows that no one will collect
that's it it's all i have it must be
enough
then go be on your way
thanks mukako we appreciate this
we have some outstanding biz to sell
remember sandra dorsett
i don't forget such things v
right this is going to kill you that was
it all right
can i not play the pachinko i wish you
could
i feel like that would have been really
cool
[ __ ] it so far dude
is this something happening here
wait a second listen to that guy
how'd you rate his chops
[Music]
weak pathetic really hold the thing
i ain't a musician but even i can tell
that's sloppy stuff
ladies and gentlemen a critic chill
chimbot
ain't half bad guys hurt me got
something he can't
take and it shows now this is how you
play
stage presence all wrong sorry
more than he keeps it but not bad
you really know how to give a guy a
compliment is that how you got your
start
street busker don't make me laugh
no time for playing my way to the top
was too busy shaking the world away
[Music]
being at the top can be worth it you
want to shake the world you know
oh world's got to feel you first
and you pay for it you spend your lyrics
laying waste to the big record corpse
who's going to
sign you then but give up your ideals
and no amount of eddies could buy him
back
alright princess at least you played
some gigs
sell those memories of yours true
played where we could parks old
factories
underground clubs had an audience from
the start
some recorded our stuff didn't even know
who we were
[Music]
mean to say i could get my hands on
[Music]
[Music]
you know rainbow cadenza is not far from
here clubby played till the band fell
apart
great spot place for people with their
heads arms straight
maybe they'll know something
okay good talk that was
something
so what does lip mean right so then what
where's your cute little ass rushing off
to
slow down treat yourself to a little
r-e-l-a-x-x-x
right here a curbside massage
no no gotta pay extra for that
i don't know what those hands can do
ain't no other way to live follow me
oh god what have i done
what have i done oh no
[Music]
children
ah
stop stop
okay
[Music]
we uh played the pokemon cards
i won with my raichu that was cool
glad they added that little minigame in
there
you see the mirror no
um
well naked pokemon
nothing wrong with it
everyone plays naked you never played
naked pokemon
cards
you're lost bro can i go up the stairs
nice
this is how i wanted to i wanted it to
be like this
don't don't don't tell my tan okay don't
come outside please
please i get one just these ones
just just once excuse me sorry
all right
even though it's perfectly normal don't
tell him okay
okay cool
yeah there will be consequences
there will be no checking on whatsapp
you hear me
[ __ ] i'm bad at driving what happened
there
just as planned hey how you doing
all right
yeah mom did send me help with anything
your mom sent me
after i boned her
after we had naked pokemon
oh i like this song
so just get off the bike here yeah
oh my god dude
hey look wait where was he
where the [ __ ] i swear i heard him
whoa
see what's the point
tarot card
what that's it
all right we got the cash
we'll make it back it's all right this
hurts me it hurts me so much but [ __ ] it
you got to do the main question got to
scratch
got the cred for the helmet job
fine i'm bro anders hellman
broke his hair man
two please make some room
sit down i hope you found them
don't see that often determination like
yours
must really need this guy matter of life
and death
i haven't heard that for a while either
bottle stays
jesus your loss
i wish kiana was real and not a
terrorist in my head you know
queen of the afterlife who would have
thunk
got a shard for you intel interesting
easy money from assault happening all
right let's do this
your helmet's not on any payroll not
officially anyway
but he does pop up in gmt's confidential
stacks
it's a kang tao subsidiary chinese corp
kang tao's been using them as a fig for
years they're masked for more sensitive
operations
all that clear
okay sure probably keeping him hidden
from our osaka
must have worked on a top secret one
second
hayden from arasaka or any other mega
corp that wants what he knows
decrypted map of upcoming kang tao
convoy roots
think hellman might be in one of them
thing is which one
take a look at the specs on this one a
lone av no ground support no linked
cargo manifests either
weird sure kang tao sometimes transports
stuff unregistered
they want to push it under the table but
catch them
no already approved in the system
but too low so definitely no cargo on
board
huh but there's a passenger list
kang tao security detail plus one vip
transfer from chan t our boy hellman
that was the good news there it is
sorry the dogs escaped pick up the pace
what's the bad news
bad news is that what i missed look
i'm starving all this
no way to jack the transport without the
ncpd picking up on
and here we're too close to kangtao we
even give that av a dirty look
their backup hustle will be on us but
right here's jackson plains narrow
corridor just outside the city
and just out of kangtal's reach yes it's
your lucky day
a dead zone i'll grab them there
gonna need a native to the area someone
who'll set up the op
cobble together the gear
even tracking that av will be a [ __ ]
familiar with the type
it's all legacy models flying around
during the war
the mammoth but they're quick plus they
pack next-gen defenses
can't take pot shots at it not even with
serious firepower
just won't work it's not about firepower
there are ways
and people who know them or who can at
least improvise on a theme
so a native know any hiccups did nothing
cool
just one pan am palmer
she can't count on her clan anymore but
she's a true nomad
she knows those lands and she will help
you
we'll have a choice won't have a choice
it does not sound entirely
not for her not for me enticing comes at
a price you can't possibly afford
can't possibly afford to blow this
chance at nab and hellman
your operation your call got a bad
feeling fee
should i pick no man
i don't think it matters why is pan am
gotta help me
i sense a catch pretty big one
occasionally
pan am moves merch for me last job
well it wasn't a good day for her she
run into a hitch
complete bust actually lost the goods
and her right
pan am will do anything to get the load
back means her dignity
i know her okay
guess i can try to help her if we don't
know where to look i mean
we do i do
fine let me hear what you know rocky
ridge
ghost time just outside night city pan
am knows where
you'll go there get the merch back
wheels too
naturally you'll call her first sending
you her deeds
finally that's all clear yep
oh i got pink boots i didn't even
realize
would you look at that you see it too
mercy right
you've gotten completely whacked when
i'm having a mystical moment
what's that chick's name the one with
the hair where is it
misty yeah more likely a neuron misfire
for victor
to check out or maybe i ask him both
doesn't matter how much you coming
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
hang on just a little longer joe
ripper's on the way
someone said there's a lot of money in a
quest
which one was it i want money
i guess we're calling panama
yo nice fanny pack a loser
this pan am be here
how did you even get this number
from rogue
claire right where's that one that's it
this thing between you and rogue
couldn't care less
got a job i want that outfit but i'm
over extended at the moment
with the merch and your car getting it
back
i can help with that the
have money main quests have uh xp
okay i see you can
looks like jack's hair
damn that was cool dude nice
shoes
oh i think she likes me
in the future everyone will have a man
bun gotcha
that's a nice car
and it's mine
arctic penguins with a hundred i'll got
to go jen's love the stream
hope everyone the best floor again thank
you very much have a good day
damn someone's writing them whatsapp is
it you can
i can't check it
oh i like this car
it's not ken i better check it then
can't be bothered now this is the
problem
hey ken how does it feel to know i'm i'm
10 times better driver than you
see this [ __ ]
see that [ __ ]
see this [ __ ]
he's crying
i made him cry i'm sorry
hey look it's ken kendache
it was pretty bad i've seen you try in
real life ken still has ptsd from the
one time i drove him in la
and we hit the freeway
it's one and only near-death experience
i was supposed to drive here but
listen it was it wasn't my fault
[ __ ]
oh yeah happy birthday by the way ken
nice
i think hey pan am
where's my car mayor
agree to help me you'll find out oh [ __ ]
no
you will not jerk me around tell me
where my car
is hey come on
calm down oh it's my mom what to do fine
know where to find the cargo and your
car you go alone
you won't get him back and you could
lose something else besides
so let's figure something out
what do you want
i got my mom uh i sent my mom the oculus
rift
the extra one i got and she's so excited
to use it one guy i gotta talk to
a corporal traveling by corp convoy no
i don't do abductions besides you'd need
many more bodies and heaps of gear to
take a convoy
it's just one av plan brood will take it
over jackson plains
[ __ ] in return info on your cargo
help in getting back what's yours you
got a deal
i don't know i [ __ ]
oh better view from here
all right deal but if you want your
thing done we'll need to get my thornton
back
first so where is it
cars in rocky ridge you're supposed to
know where that is
cars yeah my mom's a gamer hell yeah
bastard i will strangle you
rocky ridge let's go hang on
i i should think this through
[ __ ] yes we'll need backup
we have one brief stop to make on the
way wanna tell me where give me a sec
i should call the client convince them
to leave the bastard hanging going ahead
with the deal behind
rogue's bag brave i guess
or [ __ ] dumber than a drum dumber
than a drum
now
i just need you to give me a chance
buzz come on how many times have i moved
things
my mom has a hundred percent of breath
of the wild i swear she's been playing
it since it came out
after dark okay and she keeps playing it
and i don't know why don't show up
i'll take care of him she disloves it do
you even have to ask
of course i will thanks boss you won't
regret this
she's like me she just like game playing
that's like perfect gameplay game
or atmosphere if that meat had your word
and he took it
is that surprising it's called having a
reputation
you should try getting one of your own
so
where to now the aldecaldo camp
i need to see some of the old clan don't
seem too excited
that's not your concern i still have
friends yeah she finished it along
though she's just
she likes to just mess around good let's
roll
i'm like there's other good games on the
switch too mario odyssey i think you'll
like it she's like nah
breath of the wild felix you don't
understand
nice ride lots of space
no more whoa we just hit a [ __ ] car
how the hell did you land in this mess i
like the color
the air freshener and booster seat came
extra yeah you know i don't mean the car
what am i supposed to tell you that i'm
not about to let my partner rob
is this a tesla reference
what about you why do you need that
clown from the ap
this particular
when i was a kid i thought it was the
coolest thing in the world that my mom
was a gamer
i mean it's still the coolest thing in
the world
i love that as a kid it's like my mom
it's a gamer screw
what screw rogue i can't see why you
even care
because i need the money don't let her
push you around
she's not the only fixer in town yet
you're only here because she sent you
but i'm not the one bitching about it
you don't know her
not at all did she tell you she was the
one to bring me and nash together
did she tell you it slipped her mind to
mention nash was wrath and shiv
she must have had a reason to have had
her reasons you don't say
rogue won't open her mouth without
weighing the foreign against
true
i don't even know what's going on half
the time with these quests they just
talk too much
ken shh you can't criticize the game
they'll get mad at you
the dialogue is perfectly paced at all
times
i don't know where you got that from
they definitely don't speak for speaking
sake
[Music]
well would you look what the cat dragged
in
is that a ghost or is it just my
hangover
[ __ ] you too mm-hmm
and who's this my babysitter me this is
scorpio
hey two old friends
not a babysitter yeah crime
i'm deadly okay city girl the big city
got too
small for her do you have any idea how
angry the old man's gonna be when he
sees you here
i've just come by for a spell saul
needn't know a thing
the raffin screwed me over i'll get them
back but i need your help
come with me we'll thrash them the four
of us
guys you know 2077 they haven't cured
baldness still
now that was hard seriously you won't
help
well the old man told us to sit tight
and get those generators back
up after the batteries went kaput
generators
you won't help because of some goddamn
generators is this another joke
really could use your help come on
so you'll stay put because soul told you
to you couldn't care less about me
pan am this isn't about saul
it's about the clan you know that all
right listen
we can't leave camp no chance but but
soul never said a thing about gear
i have cumin and chili okay
well i'll need that rifle of yours and
some of my own speaking
take whatever you want and take care of
yourself out there
yeah thanks guys i'll grab the gear
then be out of your hair oh i think we
already are
oh i think we because i think we're
already
all right looks like you're stuck with
me
you disappointed i don't know
maybe a little yes
all right i like her
no i'll be going again soon we'll talk
next time
jackie replacement question mark
nice nice try simp
are you looking at sim huh we're staring
at i don't know that peripheral
i know hey stop stop
stop no shimping no simply stop
it [ __ ] out of you
oh what the [ __ ] is that
will you help me with this yes
i can handle
oh the box [ __ ] a few odds should be
useful
take it all right that's everything
let's go
you get that and i get a box
did you figure out your differences
what does she have here
stop stop simping oh my god dude
next time ellie i saw a guy checking out
uh
martin's ass when she left her car and
i'm like uh
okay and then a few minutes later while
i was waiting in the car the guy had
pissed his pants
and they were escorting him into a taxi
call us sometime keep an eye on rv
put it in the trunk
it's daytime by the way it's [ __ ]
[Music]
weird
can go hop in
great story i'm happy to share
i have it on video too
because first he he knocked he like
stumbled into my car and i'm like what
the [ __ ] and then some
guy was like escorting him out of the
bar
or the pub
ain't no problem having problem with
authority
those two in the army scorpion mitch
yeah
fans are boys they're on contract during
the last four
panzer boys flew those huge transporters
scorpion piloted mitch ran security they
both got some kick-ass combat implants
and a stack of really [ __ ] up
nightmares
mitch and scorpion seem good souls the
best friends a girl could ask for
i'd stay in the camp too if i were in
their shoes [ __ ] all in his generators
of course
yeah the clown comes first but i'm not
part of it anymore
still treated you like you're one of
them they care about you
do you have anyone you would call close
maybe soon could just be a matter of
time though
okay
my dad just sent me a photo of my mom
wearing the headset
[Laughter]
i skipped this ride rocky ridge empty
dusty hole
okay we have arrived
what do we do we get ready to greet the
ravens
and we have little time for that we'll
need to improvise
we should scout first broken podcast
shout out again
oh fighting time scan the devices in the
area
okay
[Music]
now rocky ridge could be any deader
it's down nothing works here
well have you found anything it's only
been three years still people still like
is it really only three years dude it
feels like ages ago
i got nada you have an epiphany the
raffins will roll in after dusk right
we will have a surprise ready for them
we need to get some power flowing
no dice nothing's up all cut off so we
plug it back in
let's check the substation you got it
oh blue item
none to quote it
scanning
found the breakers but there's no juice
on them not to worry
come down i know how to surprise the
bastards she saw somebody like jade in
there what the [ __ ]
so the intersection is powered from that
transformer substation right
the switch gear on the roof we'll flip
the switch there and everything will
light up like christmas
understood
sure so classic root good old diversion
you know it first we don't know how many
are coming
my thinking is it'll be a sizable crew
second we have to create an opening to
get to my car
if they're bunched together we won't
stand a chance so we give him a little
light show at the intersection
yes we'll breathe some life into this
dusty old town
as soon as they see the lights they'll
have to check who why and how
nova yep first we start up the control
terminal below
the gear on the roof is a hunk of junk
without it come on we'll give it a boost
from the car battery
that should do the trick wait for me by
the substation
i'll bring the car around
how long is it oh 30 meters
it looks looks good in the golden hour
look at that
nice
i guess we'll wait here
the panel looks to be in good shape i'll
make a bypass circuit to the power
supply that should do it
we'll just have to get it up and running
grab the jumper cables from the trunk
we'll boost it from the car battery
can i get the gun please they're teasing
us
great cable connected give me a moment i
need to hook everything up here
i'm done now the black rattler
there she goes i thought the old
jalapeno served us one they're so amazed
by the oculus
i've got breakfast start the terminal
inside and once the power is on in the
building get on that roof
you got it all set up on the tower we'll
have the whole intersection on a platter
nice you flip the breakers when i give
you the signal to do so understood
yes ma'am my gooper agave gamer brain
needs to
stimulate it come on force open
yeah baby
ooh we got more carrying cap sweet
switch gears got power prime we'll have
some fun at the intersection let's get
into position
ew
now we wait
remember as soon as we see them you give
us power
this isn't cyberpunk cover me just in
case
of course have i ever simp
no absolutely not what are you
doing you see her really really hard to
miss
let's take them by surprise let's try to
do this quietly
if anything happens i'll start picking
them off oh god i'm gonna have to stop
[ __ ] i got this guys
these man little boy here
easy
[ __ ] there's so many of them oh my god
should we should we hack them no
uh just one second i'm just gonna
she say now let there be light
am i supposed to shoot them now what if
i stealth them out
drop the car the driver look for the
girl
i can't go through here
i know i'm supposed to stealth around
but i really wanna just
stab aru you know
oh someone saw me
bite
are they on the roof
what's on the roof
didn't see me but here i am
oh [ __ ] they're gonna see the the body
where am i blind
why does it say there's an enemy here
[Music]
is that a fist in the toilet [ __ ] you
cyberpunk how dare you disrespect
how do i distract him
you fool
[Music]
yes they saw me
die see the one i needed oh perfect
no need to risk it fine
meet me at the city line north side no
need to risk it
wait this is sucky gun
[Music]
what the [ __ ] are they doing they're
just shooting the door
no
[ __ ]
that's what you get for playing on hard
you just instantly died
you didn't see me but here i am
inside the gun really
wrong then
[ __ ] it's tough
they saw me even in normal mode you can
get one shot
oh okay i should stop bitching them
[Music]
anything i can use to destroy
[Music]
worthy
think everybody just packed up
whoa
oh
what's hurting me
well this is a massive failure we're
fine
okay that's all right i don't mind
colorful bunch
better check that out bro
come over me man we're gonna have a
little makeup session
we're gonna play naked pokemon cards
didn't see me
but here i am
just as planned
oh
[ __ ] santaru
colleen oh we got her sniper let's use
it
nice so which one are they equally good
no
this one is garbage
i never used to sniper before i want to
try
oh it's time
can we get on the roof
cool
oh my god heal heal
heal heal heal heal heal heal heal
getting the car out of here no need to
risk it
fine meet me at the city line north side
don't get too used to her
[ __ ] i'm [ __ ]
i pressed x a million times i didn't let
me heal because we're in a cutscene
are these bulletproof glass what's
happening
that was a miss apparently
thanks
[Music]
do i get pen and sniper after maya
worth it definitely worth it
[ __ ]
[Music]
it tells me to go in here but [ __ ] it
wow
cyberpunk dabs should we put staring in
this game yes
how much serious yes that's the joke i
did it
[Music]
maya is hungry she wants food
it's almost six o'clock she gets pissed
off
i'm hitting exit it doesn't do anything
i can't there we go oh that's weird
yeah sure sure sure leave the driving to
the pros
we like a strong female protagonist you
drive sure
i don't want to drive don't worry
at last
do lights attack as well it helps a lot
king say
all right but i only upgraded my um
heavy attack that's why i use it it's
prime wheels isn't she
dreamy indeed no surprise you wanted her
back
she completes me protagonist manager
scorpion listen v
it's not over yet it's not you got the
cargo you got your car
i did not get nash who was not in rocky
ridge
the [ __ ] didn't show
pan am listen i have a plan and i don't
care
the car in the mirror i care i can hear
i want to kill it
six street away forward sorry jesus
sorry awkward i know where their little
hidey hole is
we'll take the old unfinished freeway
nearby they will not be expecting us
i'm sure of it
okay let's do it all right so where's
this hideout
i'll hop and skip away
what nash did
i placed my trust in him he was the
first person i worked with after leaving
the elder caldes
after i came to night city and i granted
him my
trust
man i wonder what's for dinner today i'm
actually been cooking such good food
lately she did pasticha
delicious
i get it i know how you feel
had someone betray me just like that
once and did you make them pay
never got the chance someone else got to
him first
but if they had it would you have done
it
no doubt without skipping a beat
let's get this over with are you ready
bro you're driving
zero miles per hour bro that's so cringe
uh where are we going this is spoopy
no but she stepped up her food it's next
level now
the [ __ ] is happening oh
it's time for fun yeah i snipe in this
distance
don't don't name me
i was a guy oh yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ]
am i dead
is that it
oh [ __ ] oops
one more shot
oh [ __ ] it's too many who do i shoot
him
i'm on fire
why
who charges it oh
holy [ __ ]
say
come on
come on
okay let's do the left shift
oh i love it
i was trying to hold it
i love it [ __ ] yeah
that's a cool thing is it only
it's only him is
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] through the rock dude
can i let go whenever i can
it will penetrate cover oh no way
guess not what the [ __ ] is he doing
got him
i'm out time to go sick on these
bastards
never mind [ __ ]
there's an epic loot somewhere
[Applause]
come on enough
can they shoot me oh they can't [ __ ]
i don't know where to go here we go
oh i think i have to shoot here
yeah clean
get that gamer loot
nice let's get the perp
give me that
what was it
i think i'm full right
nope
bro what did you say again
solve your own problems clean up your
[ __ ]
match is dead one [ __ ] cleaned happy
and the sixth street merch nash can't
deliver it anymore it's gotta be more
loot
[Applause]
i can disassemble them and upgrade the
ones i'm using yeah i should do that
so much luke all right i think we're
good let's get out of here
damn i like sniper that's fun what
bitter cold [ __ ] that broke
think she might have lost the plot mean
to say she used to be sweet and alluring
never that but she's no stranger to the
other
i definitely read strong shock and not
something else
no no fast ones come on let's meet
sunset motel
i know you're not kidding i'm certain to
be there
okay i arranged our meeting let's do the
deal and start working on hellman
agreed should be
so fun can craft ammo okay so where do i
do the crafting stuff
is it is it back in my home or can i do
it anywhere
oh this is awkward
okay i'll do that then they're here let
me do the talking
since well before you do the talking
okay so crafting
so this is i could craft this but it's
blocked because i need more items
okay but how do i disassemble them then
oh and i can craft mods
and craft ammo
okay i go to inventory
precision rifle
that does more damage
okay let's say i want to disassemble
this
oh
i'm trying it
this time
is there a quick way to do this
okay that's all the junk might as well
disassemble this
and this i'm not going to use that
ooh a tanto blade that's kind of cool
i'll keep that okay and now
can we craft anything no
epic item control component so i need to
disassemble epic opponent components
okay let's do that then
then i have a gun that was epic that
wasn't that good this one
i don't need that as well
oh these are way better
how much do i have now two whoa you
gotta disassemble a [ __ ] ton
okay what about upgrade then let's say i
want to upgrade my
i guess it's better now
let's do to level two
okay cool while i'm at it i should
probably upgrade my character sorry it's
super boring
body yes
carrying capacity might be good
health regen is up to seven dollar max
outside of combat
yeah sure yes
yes these are all really good stats
oh [ __ ] all right we'll do that later
oh i didn't even see these annihilation
increased oh
oh then reflexes is in bla okay
did i miss anything in trouble no
at least i don't think so
it's gonna be trouble i like the game
it's a buggy mess but it also makes it
for funny
moments as a streamer
but if i played it alone i'd be kind of
annoyed
how's nash doesn't seem to be answering
his phone
don't call him anymore there's no need
it's keemstar
what's this a bonus of some sort
bonus meme we work together
hmm change tunes like you change clothes
girl first class merch
january your life lives i'm bringing
back book reviews
in january so everything's in order next
year check your account
should be pretty plush in a couple of
minutes it's been a pleasure
but i believe rogue's the one who was
dependent you're all right
think you were in the tip let's roll
that one well nice come on is there a
way that could have gone to [ __ ] then
what the [ __ ] is happening here what the
[ __ ]
oh they're just talking yeah what
it is how it is it blows
[Laughter]
it is how it is wiped six streets
[ __ ] blows
pretty good day for pan am palmer the
day's not over
yet you still have a chance to piss me
off
come on breathe
hello noah let's get a drink i feel good
new biz or new friends back there
take a wild guess is everything good
with you
did those bozos come around again
raphael's
nah it's been quiet they'll be back sure
enough
this place has seemed worse what can i
get you
brosif two of them bro say that
clinics rippers
don't really feel like drinking don't
let that deter you
i don't aim too
god damn slow down girl another one over
here
thanks noah cheers let me know if you
need anything else
let's talk about that anders guy time
you look to my needs
what's the plan for hellman i've come up
with a plan a first draft
but i need to sleep on it work it out
then we can talk about the details
i think it best to rent rooms here just
to stay in the area
we'll get to work around midnight it'll
help keep us out of sight
agreed yes but
[Music]
what's gotten into you maybe we rent
just one room
good idea noah has two twin beds in
every room
we'll save some money what
okay i won't insist separate beds got it
no one will need a room twin beds just
for tonight
i'll go catch a few winks
we're gonna play pokemon right
[Applause]
don't judge me noah okay
okay
i'm not it's not it's not stamping
euro dollars nice
let's see how we look
oh what since when did we get
bald
what the [ __ ] dude what happened to our
hair
did i miss something
there's a glitch oh
it's nothing creepy about going in a
girl's room and just
smiling in the mirror nothing wrong with
that
good night
hello
what is that for me
i can't
oh my name is dakota smith if you're
looking for jobs out here you will find
them with me
what nation you ride north dakota the
alda caldos
and now now i don't i see
we will be in touch fee
we're good oh yeah we're good what'd i
miss
meet pan am at midnight hey
hey hello i'm just checking the
suspension
the hydraulics have to be shipped shape
we're in for a bumpy ride
guess that is all she wrote i'm just
checking the suspension
the hydraulics have to be shipped shape
we're in for a bumpy road yeah you did
say that
can't complain
and you reasonably rested i think you
had nightmares
you screamed a few times really don't
worry
i'm accustomed to that sort of thing
when mentioned scorpion came back from
the war they tossed and turned
night after night for months this went
on
whatever it is it'll pass yeah let's
hope so
it was kiana reeves he's in my head he's
a terrorist you have to believe me
come up with anything for helman i mean
as a matter of fact i did
look here
okay tell me
we're the wrench the cutter is the av
and the screwdriver is where the av
should bury its nose cone in the dust
now you must be wondering how we get the
av to do that so what's that hmg of
yours
my gun will be useful elsewhere this
caliber would barely dent the armor of a
heavy hitter like that
there are other ways here the clamps are
solution
a sat wave power station
um sat wave power station yes
we need to break into it so far so good
but then what and then we strike we hit
the av
with an emp of course we do as soon as
the av
is in range we cause an electromagnetic
pulse
the on-board electronics should fail out
right meaning what
engines will shut down everything will
shut down engines included
drive navigation communication systems
aren't you uh counting chickens we can't
actually know the av will fly over the
station
of course we can't but we don't have to
you'll see
it's bound to be quite a ride but not
one you'll regret
i've got everything planned out
all right let's ride great hop in
it's cold out here
okay all right okay
whoa what the [ __ ]
who owns this power station gov or corp
is there any difference who do you think
pulls the government's strength this is
the main question right it has to be
just wondering whose toes were about to
step all over
oh i asked look around it is simple
everything you see is owned by a
corporation
you like to mess with the corpse huh
whatever gave you that idea
oh wait scratch that rogue
nash the wrath
close your ears what
somebody changed something completely
different weirdest thing
you've ever transported go because me
i had to carry a real organic iguana
once
[Laughter]
yup someone put them in a deep sleep
this guy's good at small talk i can't do
that
man i made a [ __ ] load off that job your
turn
think you can beat that the deputy
finance director of calcas
whoa i'd say it's a tie
dead in the trunk okay fine you win
we've almost reached the damn we'll make
a quick stop here
bro it's the middle of the road are you
current
i want you to be able to use the gun too
and shut up our chances in general
yes finally finally
you look so spoopy stop it how should i
connect
personal link how else just watch the
jack sometimes you have to jig a little
bit all right we'll jiggle
wired in wait a moment diagnostics first
[ __ ] it keeps giving me an
error odd let me work around it
and now pan am here's johnny
out in the middle of bum [ __ ] nowhere
great work hey here's johnny that has a
virus
the one in the nape of your neck
just some malware don't worry about it
it's a keanu reese's a terrorist in my
head it's whatever
just a little malware you get used to it
eventually screw you
will it affect the calibration we shall
see
i wish chianti was real man not just
some vegetarian imagination in my brain
man
good next target single shot
am i blind where does she want me to
shoot
oh okay just one more
longer round great we're done i think
now that wasn't so bad was it
calibration's fine but your soft could
really use an update
scanner controllers all a couple of
generations hey look it's downtown l.a
hey if you'd rather better take the
bargain bin at a kabuki flea market
i can help you with that you know yes
sure the most important thing is that it
works now
so where's this power station you will
see in a moment
yeah right i know a spot why is keanu
reeves in our head he is already in our
hearts
we don't need this sabotage corporate
power station
jump a corporate transport kidnap a
corporate
suit there's a plug for the word corpo
or do you have a point
no what you're starting to remind me of
me
50 years back minus the charisma
an impressive [ __ ]
maybe we can just kiana please
you're asian stop it
could be something to that i suppose
what happened to us
it must have had some effect you're more
like me than you think
you'll see but it goes both ways
maybe you're becoming more like me yeah
no way
all looks clear the area looks deserted
i see no patrols
the huge thing is the collection unit
and see the antennas
each antenna collects microwave energy
from satellites in orbit
that's then converted into electric
power
oh antennas run all the way down the
interstate
and they're linked which is to your
advantage we just need to mess with the
collection unit
a chain reaction will follow each one of
the antennas will emit an emp
burst the av will be like a flying for a
spider's web
i think it's happening off the pulse at
the right moment let's go get her
once we reach the station i'll set up a
bypass for the detonator
you just overload the systems
overload the system yes ma'am when do i
start
though hoping that's not too complicated
is it
it shouldn't be you just turn everything
up as far as it'll go
crank it up to 11. got it
so what now we wait we should time our
arrival to the av flight
got it
good the game is quiet and i'm loud
really
done anything like this maybe that's
better downing in av
by myself no why do you ask
thought you would have done something
like this with your clan
no we did take back one of ours from a
convoy once
count is still chilly what we're doing
now
the risk is so much greater you don't
miss it
what jobs like this being in a clan
being
part of a family i could ask you the
same
how do you feel all in your own
hey now didn't answer the question
because i have no answer to give yet
i just got louder from that
one last time we drive in [ __ ] up the
system
and get the hell out of there hold on
tight this could get a little bumpy
get ready okay i'm ready
i think myself got keys
oh you're here
[Music]
we had to train for that
[Music]
find the controls i'll connect the
detonator quick fee
damn this is really cool
[ __ ] i'm fine
yeah my estimating food in case you're
here
do you see that all lit up and flinking
like a girl
you wanted 11. you gotta lift yeah
let's get out of here before it lights
us up too
damn she's actually a really good driver
i thought here i thought i was good get
the [ __ ] out before something happens to
the chance of the tip
you know i was just about to set up a
picnic maybe the layout work
watch out the next one mate johnny
johnny
okay on this hmm okay i'm fine
it's it's okay just it's okay i'm fine
yeah just
dealt to the [ __ ] out not the cleanest
job perhaps
but it still went well what about the
detonator is it working that was fun
i shot four turrets and i clicked f
three times
yeah that was
cliff something we'll set up it should
give us a good view of the antennas
and then we wait okay
okey dokey smokey pokey moki
blokey on the
how do we know when don't worry i'll
have eyes on it
you just wait for my signal then set off
that pulse
they won't know what hit them
and by the way what we are about to
knock a multi-million euro dollar kang
tao asset clean out of the sky
how does that make you feel
blasting [ __ ] exactly what the doc
ordered and that's exactly what i like
that's a yellow is that what we're
taking down just noticed
what it's quiet the home of the city
people's voices the smells
it's all gone wind just intensifies it
think i forgot quiet exists
well maybe not the smells i mean the
coyotes
rather hard to miss that was just the
air freshener and you thought
ha ha screw you you'd do better to focus
on the av
keep your eyes open
oh it's there coming from pacifica
all right get ready one more second okay
one more
now boom there she is
[ __ ] what's happening [ __ ] tastic
[ __ ] hell
fan [ __ ] test oh there we go
pan am the engines are still running
[ __ ] they're getting away they're going
nowhere
we got to go after it give me a moment
pan am what are you doing
whoa
that's how you [ __ ] she's crazy
we got the bastard let's go
we got it no way it stays in the air
after a blast like that
[Music]
you catch that over tv
i repeat do not approach the
the pulse is interfering
[Music]
get red they're trying to slow it down
we won't let them kind of hard to aim
[ __ ]
which one do i focus on
stab it
[ __ ]
just stab it again bro
oh you okay
where are the drugs now i can actually
shoot them
cool
whoa calm down now that girl
saw it behind that hill
pan am you okay [ __ ] ricochet
i think you can manage sure i'll live
don't worry hey man where are you
hello perfect keep broadcasting over an
open channel
just in case they missed you the first
time god i swear
something's not right did you hear those
shots
v something happened to them let's check
it out i see the work
but no scorpion
looks expired
v connect to the drone we'll scan the
area we have to get our bearings
okie dokie let's roll you connecting to
visual
fee if they caught the alta caldis if
they got mitch and scorpion i can't
i don't know i know don't spoil it i'm
in control
[Music]
whoa i'm a [ __ ] drone oh this looks
sick dude
oh no no no
[ __ ] i'm sorry your clan
all to call this yes
well this is a [ __ ] plane all of them
but bro there's loot they drop hella
loot dude
it's all good
scan the area mitch he's alive
they have them
the operatives those
oh no
you oh they're there
i don't want to let me scan
yes they're dead
all it doesn't let me
if they don't worry it doesn't let me
am i crazy they'll tear us to shreds if
we get too close
can we take it down somehow maybe but we
have to get there first
okay we'll finish this with some samurai
sheep
as i could have warned them this is all
my doing
why in the hell were they probably
keeping helmet in the av the fools
mind that launcher it will blow us to
bits if we approach
you're already blown to bits don't be an
idiot this is just a
kiss but the scratch all right nice
let's see this
stay in the car sorry but you're just
going to slow me down
[ __ ] those are my people out there
i get that launcher out of the way i'll
let you know then you go in
and help me with the rest deal
yes sir yeah i still have mitch's rifle
i will try to cover you from here good
idea
nice move all right
nice freaking finger licking
beep beep squishing
all right
she could die if you leave her behind
that seems stupid it should be the
opposite
oh
it's part of the plan really
i have a feeling that thing is going to
be a problem
is there anywhere i can get covered i
can't move
how do i get that down
oh that wasn't so hard
that's the guy behind me what's
happening
[ __ ] this game is glitchy
oh my god
you didn't see me but here i am
robots cannot be a headshot that makes
sense
[Music]
you'd be shot oh great
definitely meant to do that
hello give me the loot yeah
oh he did f
in chat yeah
yes give me that [ __ ]
oh sick rides they're mine now because
they are dead right
they wrote it on their will i remember
where's the purple loot
is that turret shooting me
stop
i want the purple loot
guess that works too i'm coming for you
some yeah i already did it i already did
it come on
all right so i get this one right
because uh
if i get the bike please
[Music]
open the door i'll cover you
now step back back
toss your weapons or i'll shoot i repeat
you don't see this [ __ ] you're in now
you shoot him and a millisecond later
you'll eat lead too
i let him go
oh [ __ ] nice
i was a hair guy just some scratches
you're [ __ ] morons did you get hit
hang on girl i'll patch you up nothing
let's go
we couldn't retreat him they regrouped
so fast
started shooting rockets and [ __ ] i lost
everyone
everyone yeah scorpio is he here
mitch mitch he's
he's safe here i'm sorry i didn't make
it in time
no no are you sure
no he is that his bike
scorpion the rest i'm sorry we didn't
get here sooner
they were good people great people they
didn't have to die here
i should have stopped him i tried he
wouldn't have listened to you either
never was much of a listener stubborn
bastard
i'm guessing since you were out here you
were out here for the yeah i like the
answer remarks so my question is why
i see doing it sorry i need the guy
who's riding this av
you know anything see anything took him
with him in
our cars where west small unit
your passenger's entourage must be
looking for a way to call base
so you're the ones who hit him with that
emp yeah we tried to warn you but
couldn't connect if they took your cars
we might be able to follow their tracks
i'll go after him stay with mitch i'll
be fine
i am going with you i promised i would
help
besides those bastards killed scorpion
i won't let that go i had a feeling
she'd say that
go i'll call my people we'll take care
of things here
we'll leave my ride here just in case
just watch the gun it likes to jam
we'll go by bike yes kang tao lost
contact with their av probably looking
for it
better hurry but pan am what
you're coming back for her right i
promise bro i need to stop playing but i
can't let's get going
which one this one is cooler even though
it's got all the luggage [ __ ]
excuse me we're not
let's ride hope they didn't go far we'll
see
the tire tracks start there we'll follow
them
our guys are here let's follow
find them
you don't
oh [ __ ] yeah
i knew you that well probably better
than i know myself
in the city oh
look you're alive watch out
it's a crap i'm dead i'm
[Music]
that from my dead you [ __ ]
clean
can't see my crosshair for all the white
i'll kill you
oh oh will you
sorry about that one bro better hurry
then
yes leg
is there any loot here
uh okay let's get the bike
that's hers where's mine
just as i parked it
left a few peeps behind at the airstrip
rest went with helmet
no one has done the same
[Music]
yeah i know i can shoot through the
walls let's do a shortcut
let's keep it cool hey guys
uh maybe not they can't see me from here
drones patrols definitely set up shop
here
i see they must have helmet locked up
somewhere
buffy see that the pumps look pretty
good
not what you would find if the place
were closed the bastards might have
managed to call for transport
no soon enough
where is he looking
i don't know i couldn't get the terminal
don't turn around don't turn around not
even on broadband
what so all night city and your mom
could hear a kang
av got shot of course
you come with me [ __ ] you hear
this
the last thing i'm gonna [ __ ] i don't
know why i said that
okay he's dead
i'm in try to save something hard and
nice
it's not this i switch people can't do
it all right
is there anyone in here oh [ __ ] that was
something
get the legs quick
legs
legs
legs
[Music]
[Applause]
legs
oh nice
can't loot it
give me your [ __ ] legs hand them over
and your head no
i'm alive what is that a glitch
no oh the thing blew up
okay okay i gotta go sorry guys
fun playing hope you guys enjoyed as
well i like it
very nice it's picking up
thanks for joining guys appreciate you
thanks for all the new members
appreciate you all goes to charity very
nice support it
have fun uh see you guys new video
coming up right now brofist
there it is all right see you guys